another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do at the foundation no promising to  make people into magical girls listen  lots of us have dreamed of becoming  heroes with magical powers fighting for  love truth and justice and battling evil  in a pretty dress i know i have but  don't let dr bright trick you into  thinking he's able to dispense that kind  of power the amulet is not a soul gem  nor is it imbued with any supernatural  powers that can be connected to the moon  or any of the planets in our solar  system please don't trust him even if he  promises to include a magical girl  outfit that sounds creepy if he says  that to you spray him with some pepper  spray please